but
first okay today i'm going to be
transmitting electricity wirelessly 34
feet
to light a neon light bulb and you know
he's going to do something to become a
super villain right
he's going to make a ball yeah he's
getting some sort of halt the city
hostage
but no you know what's going to happen
in one day one day in the middle of a
very busy town square there's just gonna
be this player piano and it's gonna
start
people gonna gather around it and then
it's gonna go
down
filled with nails he's he's a batman
villain
he's gonna make an adam west batman he's
gonna make a gigantic tesla coil that
demolishes the city
you all laughed at me
why did you all laugh at me you should
have taken me seriously
and if i have enough time i will also
light a fluorescent light bomb
we live in anxiety
[Laughter]
you want to know how i got this afro
that's my hero this guy's like
oh [ __ ] and he already hit doctor he's
[ __ ] dr
frankenstein too so he already has a
name but he already has a villain name
i'll do this for you royce you wanna
know how i got this afro
my father was a drinker and a fiend and
one night he goes off crazier than usual
mommy gets the victrola out to defend
herself he doesn't like that one
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
the old picture pull out
i said run ma he's winding it
oh
no i love this guy his getaway vehicle
is like a giant blimp
right the [ __ ]
hot air balloon everything he has this
old timey i'm all
in oh god
actually actually roy's i'm putting in
the i'm putting in the group chat
uh putting in the group chat i found a
footage of him actually stealing a car
to get away from his
most recent attack okay uh just just
it's in the it's in the group chat
okay i got it uh let's see here oh god
this is him stealing is stealing it oh
no a runabout
i'll steal it no one will ever know
i love the idea of him being a super
villain oh [ __ ]
here i got it too oh no
okay today i'm going to be transmitting
electricity wirelessly 34 feet
to light a neon light bulb and if i have
enough time i will also light a
fluorescent light bulb
here is the magnifying transmitter which
will be i was lying
i was kidding about the tesla coil i was
looking
here is the receiving coil which will be
receiving the electricity to light that
neon light bulb right here
the bottom end of the receiving coil is
grounded to the swimming pool
through that wire right there he just
has
some some blonde some blonde dame
tied up in the pool
about to drop a live wire into it
oh it's always a piano you're right
piano hanging over
um okay
oh man we have to be afraid now okay are
we
i i'm scared man he's too powerful and
he's too smart
royce royce gets a mysterious vinyl in
his p.o box he plays it
all of a sudden it starts releasing some
like weird smoke as it plays and he just
passes out and wakes up in this tutorial
so i'm like oh cool vinyl let me see
what this
is
[Music]
welcome to my lair i want to play a game
as you can see you're surrounded by 37
pianos
only one of them will let you go if you
can play beethoven's
uh oh mozart's owed to joy
imperfection [ __ ]
you imagine
[Music]
[Laughter]
but hold on it's like this here it is
oh no
he just stopped
here is the magnifying transmitter which
will be transmitting the electricity
here is the receiving coil which will be
receiving the electricity to light that
neon light bulb right there
the bottom end of the receiving coil is
grounded to the swimming pool
through that wire right there and in the
swimming pool this family of six
they claim to have something to live for
and the top of it goes into that light
bulb and the other side of the light
bulb
or the other pole instead of another
instead of going after people who don't
appreciate
life like jigsaw he just goes after
people who don't embrace
old tech yeah exactly
he's not against tech just anything
built after the 1894.
[Music]
which is running through they call him
the mozart
killer that's a good fight this wire
right here
and it goes up and over this fence into
the earth right over there
here we go oh no it's an old season
his neighbors must love him oh [ __ ]
and you know he's probably
you probably sorry he probably also
gives you like a speech you know
he'll give you a speech he'll be like
before he electrocutes you
you know he's about and you know he's
about to strike because you come home
the lock on your door's broken and you
smell old licorice
[Music]
he's sitting there and he goes did you
know that nikolai tesla
used to had his patents stolen by
uh thomas edison
spinning facts only shocks your nuts he
worked at a power
he worked at a power company for you and
for years think about that
that great mind being misused well
that's not going to happen to me
and then he shocks
play play can you just play scary music
royce
sure hold on
[Music]
hello where where am i where am i
victor talking machine company was
founded by engineer eldridge r
johnson who has been manufacturing
gramophones for inventor emily berliner
to play his disc records after a series
of legal wranglings between berliner
johnson and her farmer
oh no they killed me
[Music]
jesus christ passing oh you [ __ ] get
murdered
hold on i'm gonna do another one
i'll do another one hold on
what are you doing why are you doing
this a player piano is a self-playing
piano containing a pneumatic or
electro-mechanical mechanism that
operates the piano action via program
music recorded on perforated paper
in rare instances metallic roles with
more modern implementations using midi
the rise of the player piano
grew with the rise of the master
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man okay